so I think about half of you know me I'm
David Michael Wallace I'm one of the
partners at Lila and today since hardly
anybody has heard of Lila we've been
sort of working away writing code and
being accidentally stealthy I start with
the 50,000 foot overview of what Lila is
going to talk about why we built Lila
based on what it is let's start to
justify that and then start you to tell
about some of the architectural
decisions we made and actually then
actually show you running code because
that's always better than an actual talk
and then I'm gonna do a breadth-first
path through this because I don't know
how much anybody knows especially in the
student audience out in the camera land
about what a I used to be and what AI is
today and and why why why why I care and
so I can do our betrayed amounts of
depth-first question-answering
when we're done for that so quick who
where and when we're small team we're
not affiliated with any big organization
we're just working on our room we're not
part of Stanford or MIT or you know
Google or any big company
we're just funding it ourselves we're a
bunch of old farts primarily from the AI
lab in the Seymour Papert Marvin Minsky
era both of those guys have been very
influential on on what we're working on
we haven't been publishing any papers
we've just been writing running
preferring to write running code and
we're we're self-funded although if
anybody wants to pull out their
checkbook we're willing to change that
mode but that's not the purpose of the
call talk today so in a nutshell what is
Lila okay well Lila is like a two slides
the first thing is how is it Lila think
of of the world right it's a fundamental
representation based on functional
semantics okay that means if I call if I
take some action what do I believe we'll
have what happen as a result of that
action okay and it builds out of those
you can think of them as I'll come to
that later is like little capsule
networks active capsule networks if
you're familiar with that
what it isn't is a traditional neural
network or perceptron system there's no
cat perceptron and meatloaf tat
perceptron that he used addition to
disambiguate between what's that what's
that thing in the picture because in
fact what constituted cat is really an
emergent phenomenon and to say is that a
cat or is that not a cat really depends
on the context with which you're asking
the question what why you want to ask
that question you know is I something I
want to eat or something you want to
touch it might be hot or unsanitary and
you know how to allow you to to search
quickly you know because you'll use a
whole different set of discriminatory
activities when you're outdoors you
probably not even consider you're gonna
find a meatloaf when you're walking in
your garden but a cat is is quite likely
to be there so that's when we meet
semantics we mean a system that actually
takes a meeting in context into account
not just when taking action or planning
but even at the level of individual
state items okay another core difference
from from what's considered AI today is
all of the core data structures are
inherently composable so your state
vectors of course can be primitive
States like there's a little patch of
blue right there or my hand happens to
be at this location but they can also
encompass synthetic results or require
computation to actually perform and
we'll talk about that a little later but
that's for things that's how you build
up systems to so the system can develop
an understanding of hidden state object
persistence and things like that but
still use these synthetic items just
like they would use any any primitive
item likewise plans are completely
composable goals when you want to
achieve goal you can break them down and
you could also expect them which gives
you two other kinds of capabilities
composable might mean that I might have
an item that has represents a bottle
that is that's got some liquid on it on
the table and I know a lot of other
properties about this bottle that that
the system has learned on its own such
as you know you don't want to tip it
over because things come out or
tends to be heavy doesn't tend to move
on its own and that all that cluster of
state factors can be used elsewhere
likewise when planning you can just
decompose a plan into some simpler plans
which you'll see there and and build
there for more complex plans out of them
so this is composable in the column in
the standard computer science sense of
composable let's guess what I should say
architectural e the work is based on the
constructivist model of Jean Piaget I
don't know if I mean people are familiar
with him he was by the way
Seymour's PhD advisor so there's an
interesting piece of of continuity there
which has been very influential on the
design of this on on all of us
our design you might have seen I'll talk
about in a moment that that Leela is an
agent I said that in the summary and and
Leela's design is based on what humans
do because it's very important to build
systems that behave exhibit common sense
that people are comfortable working with
and those things are grounded in and how
humans behave doesn't mean that we're
true Manta guys we're trying to actually
emulate the new you know neural
structure of human beings but you're
guided by what kind of failure most
people have how child children develop
and Lelia develops following PJ's
analysis of how human development human
childhood development works I have a
little slide on that in a moment and
like a human baby it boots up knowing
nothing really about the world it's only
state inputs are primitive inputs that
is proprioceptive inputs for example
visual inputs from from the eye and over
time
Lila starts to learn that oh if I move
my hand I see something move in my
visual field let me do an experiment and
see oh okay that is actually something I
can control and the idea that that's
actually hand that later it can use as
an effector and do things evolve through
experimentation and Pro and and
development in the world
so Lila Lila doesn't start with any pre
primed knowledge about the world
speech recognition has a very very
simple computer vision of the schematic
computer vision right now Lila only runs
in simulation we were saying that
outside in the corridor there's a little
bit of disagreement on our team whether
we should if you're in simulation you
can really look at your algorithms on
the other hand when you do I owe you
learn a lot of stuff about what you're
doing so we're doing it we're just
starting to do a little bit of IO right
now yes Lila has demonstrated object
learning object permanence say-so one of
our most recent accomplishments we just
sort of gotten to the edge of that but
yes Lila learned that on her own okay
now it's an agent that's the sort of
software ok well what are you doing with
this software ok Lila is an agent
modeling the but following developing
like a child is Lila's not just a
program or an algorithm or a singular
single thing yeah there is
there's no insight in why it is I
haven't a because people always say he
and that bugs me that people always say
he in English and actually Lila
coincidentally one of one of my
colleagues thought up the name we all
liked it happens to be my aunt's name so
automatically when I think of Lee light
I like to she so there's no insight to
be read from it so Lila is as a
general-purpose agent Lila is not
designed to solve a specific problem so
there's some pretty amazing results that
have come out I mean we see them every
day I really like geometrics actually
recent paper on on Mario and of course I
love alphago but the alphago machine was
really designed to play go right and
geometrics program was really designed
to play Mario and Leela I'll show you
actually at the very end of this legal
playing Mario and just to put the
punchline on my slide tell you that now
it's exactly the same copy of Leela that
was wrote NuvaRing in the book in the
blocks world ok no extra software added
to it for her
so since she's not designed solve a
specific problem her interface to the
outside world or to the simulated world
is how she her state vectors are
initially entirely created from what her
senses tell her okay and how does she
build more complex systems so I'll talk
about that later in the presentation but
important parts of that is she makes her
own hypotheses and tries to assure that
now she does have some heuristics baked
into her some which have come from
Piaget for example you'll see a child
through the video they'll often just
repeat something immediately when they
pick something up they drop it they pick
it up and they drop it do that a few
times so that they can get a bit of
statistical power and why not do that
when as soon as you do something
interesting why not repeat it
immediately because you know you're in
the situation you might never be in that
situation again
and so the few who is Jesus some innate
heuristics to help guide her learning
but ultimately her learning of behavior
of the world comes from statistical
knowledge and statistical power she will
make plans hypothetic plans and test
them out and those plans were going back
to composability then become actions
that are just as first-class as the
primitive actions that have come from
the IO IO system the she makes plans
either based on goals they have some
video where we actually tell her hey put
your hand in the upper corner of your
visual fields or get your hand into the
middle of your fovea and or but if we
haven't told her what to do then she
plays she explores right she's like oh
I've got these things or maybe not I'm
not really statistically sure you know
whether they're really true or I can
really depend on them or a lot can I
find a way to get myself in a situation
where I can test them out which is what
we like to say we all see children to
them but we all did ourselves when we
were children
okay since you can do all this we get
some other cool stuff you know if you
can do explanations our explanations are
really boring you'll hear them but over
time we think we shall actually be able
to learn
she has full power of her reasoning
system to construct sentences as well
she'll eventually learn what kind of
explanations are germane and which ones
cause people to get bored if you were to
use PR J's model she's like a 14 year
old 14 month old child that's when you
start start to get a bit of object
permanence in start to develop language
of course 14 real 14 month olds can
stand up and do a bunch of things that
Lila can't but by this standard that's
about where she is so now I'm gonna talk
about why do I care why do I worry why
we even want to go into this into this
problem okay well here's a good one
right I want how to ride around in
self-driving cars and I don't about you
but I prefer not to be killed by them
and if I know that any self-driving car
on the market well that people actually
putting on roads today would happily
drive across that bridge and I myself
would not drive across that bridge right
now given that there's a boat carrying
part of the bridge away with it okay huh
yeah it's a dead giveaway to me right
but with these hand built planners and
hand built vision systems that people
are using today you know nobody's
thought about this scenario and brought
you probably end up in the water okay
here's another thing that we want to be
able to solve right you want to have
state that's not you want to use covert
state right state that's not in the
image and I think we've all seen have
you seen this vicarious paper where they
took the pac-man pac-man solver and they
just translate it one pixel across it's
completely unable to solve the pac-man
game right because pac-man solver is
doing all that state on the string of
bits with no semantics about them and
you know comple montezuma's revenge
because it's God hidden state well these
are problems that you know you know I
look at this picture and I can you know
immediately flash on the fact that
there's this guy lying down but then I
realized that the riders look three four
- and you know and it's like these kinds
of problems we do them all every day
right and yet what set of neural
networks can you build to solve that
problem if that's your only tool okay
here's another really important problem
okay because I was just looking after my
parents for the past couple of weeks you
know if I see them pick up a newspaper I
know they still read newspapers on paper
and when they pick one up I know
immediately just say oh you know they
don't have their glasses on and just
tell them right and that involves a
tremendous amount of of hidden state I
had to have a model of who the other
person is how they function how they're
relates to how I function I have to have
built all that state that state that we
just don't believe is can be entered by
hand or written by you know or
algorithms that can be all written by
hand that has to be it has to involve
continuous incremental learning that's
based on on the environment at which
it's working and then of course you want
to know why right and basically
debugging everyone talks about I want an
explanation why well they really mean is
they want debugging and actually it
turns out that debugging and planning
and learning are actually all the same
tasks you need the system to be screwed
about internally screw Tabo so we can
say oh I made I myself made this plan
and I want to understand why it failed
okay I want to be able to make a plan to
be able to tell ahead of time why it's
failed if I can do that I can actually
tell you now another thing is that when
you've got millions of nodes in your in
your graph structure you're not going to
debug them with DDT right so you're
gonna have to actually ask the system to
use its own tools to tell you what's
going on we don't know how far this
scales because humans are actually
notoriously terrible at actually
explaining what they do they just
confabulating an hour an explanation ex
post facto but we're not as big as a
human yet so right now Lila is actually
able to create some explanations and
we'll give them I'll show you
the reason why it's important to say
that these elements are tightly
integrated is that's what gives the
system resilience when things change and
allows it to actually make calculus as
to the validity of the plans it's it's
made before it does or what to do when
they fail so that's why do we even care
about these cases right well automation
you know every time people come up with
automation they decide they've got
machines that can think right my
favorite machine actually is the
governor right it's a very simple device
it does exactly what a human can do you
know measure the spring tension on a
spring yet it does what it can be human
cannot do which is do it continuously it
you know 2,000 rpm but typically you
know we've you we apart from actual
machines like a a windmill that grinds
grain or a house building or something
machines actually make decisions make
very very trivial decisions right the
Industrial Age was built on machines
whose programs were given to them their
goals were given to them and the
operator was there to do all that other
stuff that couldn't be simplified and
you know 200 years come by and we've got
neural networks that are basically a
wonderful filters and discriminators but
fine when all the state is Cova is overt
and you can look at the x-ray you can
tell a lot about what's going on but
they're very fragile as we know and what
we really want to solve is you know we
don't want the same thing that just
solves a picture of somebody's spine in
a radio you know in an x-ray picture to
be driving our cars well they're not
adequate right they're still full of
handwritten code and you cannot trust
handwritten code right all these cases
of either very small variations of data
or the outdoors the real world was very
huge amounts of data or where all these
systems failed because they'd have no
they have no model of common sense it's
easy to say they don't have common sense
but they have no model of common sense
because they've only got a model of
what's in the handwritten handwritten
network in which data were provided them
and you know where that goes
I think we've all seen this great paper
on on
tax on on on image recognition has
everybody seen Oh at least some of these
are pretty good like that one no I can't
see it but couple up we got a
screwdriver the soccer ball it's in the
second slow you know you can kind of see
why it kind of looks like a soccer ball
but the system has no concept of what a
soccer ball really is it only has its
own data set and therefore either over
fits or under fits because that's all it
knows so you've got to use a human at
the end of the day to decide whether
it's really found a soccer ball or not
Siri notoriously has the same problem it
has no sense of state and so humans are
continually puzzled by Siri right I like
this one Siri I'm bleeding really bad
can you call me an ambulance okay from
now on I'll call you an ambulance
no it's funny right because of course
it's funny because we know it's stupid
Siri has no idea of what you're really
trying to accomplish when you say call
me an ambulance so she just over fits
and does something and you know when
people actually care then they just
don't let people get close to them right
and actually on my previous slide
there's a picture of an elevator
automatic elevator because that's the
robot that most people use right outside
that most people don't even come in
contact with a robot why because it's
just too dangerous the world is flat you
could seal off the end and you go off
wherever your ships go off to as example
because a rocket well yo you could do
lela all the arguments that the flat
earthers get and really could
potentially could potentially as if she
had no other outside outside knowledge
to bring to bear in fact and in fact you
know humans that's right humans also
overfit very gradually but you know
what's really good and this goes back to
self-driving car is that we don't over
fit in the car case very often in fact
we have a whole bunch of strategies to
use right I
actually spend any time worrying about
what that thing is that flew into the
road I just slowed down do I have the
time to adjust it I over fit on things
that don't matter you know global
warming nuclear war stuff that really
isn't gonna matter if a flat earth or
vac or anti-vaxxers but on the stuff
that people really care about
I don't over I almost never over fit on
putting a glass down on a table or know
whether to be moved I don't know we're
so far away from that I don't know yeah
right so when I go back to sing well
Lila is not a program or an algorithm
it's because you know Lila uses or
brings a whole bunch of tools to bear
I'd love to say the Society of mine but
we're a long way from we're a long way
from that you know Marvin but you know I
mean I've been through several waves of
this remember at the expert systems that
seems like a really great idea right ksl
just down the road here actually worried
about expert systems and it's just you
know not only they brittle but the cost
of putting them together was too high
oh well then there's you know psyche I'm
wasted how many years of my life I spent
on on psych
I might even generated that picture and
you know huge amounts of human human
time put into it but without any actual
semantic binding to anything it's just a
exercise in abstraction and the neural
networks they're deep learning they're
pretty great but guess what
what are the big careers in AI these
days cleaning data right that's where
the big hiring is in cleaning data and
then they're just had written programs I
mean they're okay that's a little unfair
but I mean they're not the internal
structure of them is not self-organized
you write the program by how you connect
the layers way so there's still a
handwritten program and the question is
how can get the program's to work for
themselves well you need traditional
computer science okay
this picture I was driving I was
actually in a hurry because I was
driving to an it to a hospital I didn't
take the picture on that when I was on
my first trip by but I knew to slow down
and prepare for sharp left turn
and I showed this picture to somebody
who will go nameless who was running a
major self-driving car company and the
answers to this you know like the week
after I was in this picture he's like
first of all we will have seen
everything and and in fact it's true
right
san Francisco's map free every three
days San Francisco is remapped and yet
what happens between those three days I
spent all the interesting stuff happens
right you can't plan for everything
right
the uber guys ran over a woman walking a
bicycle because they even saw her their
vision system and you're on that saw her
but the handwritten planner no one had
thought to say don't run over women
walking bicycles right don't drive over
bridges of which boats have not have
taken away a piece I mean I personally
have never seen this in the flesh and I
still would not drive over this right
and then the thing is you can't compute
everything right I mean you cannot
compute the power set of all the ways to
put these engine parts back together
becomes computationally intractable and
yet humans by using abstraction and
having an eternal model of how pieces
should go together
do a pretty good job humans have some
hardware assists that we're not showing
one putting a computer you've got bin
packing hardware in your brain things
like that but you're not going to do it
with a flat semantic free model where
you try out everything every case that
is not scalable so Lina does it
differently okay as I said before comes
from objects and actions what are the
state changes I expect to see if I take
this action because you know can I put
the world in the state I want it to be
well I can't do that unless I put it in
this other state so we could make a plan
make a plan to do that there is no
single share option if I'm walking
around and I have Ally the robot with me
and I'm feeling weak I want to sit down
in a chair but what if I'm out in the
woods there's no chair none of us would
think twice about sitting on that stump
or this room is full I've got a
hamburger or something with me I want to
put it on a table I'm not even gonna
think twice I'm just gonna turn this
chicken down and put down this thing
that I think all of us would use the
chair for a table in fact we're talking
I probably
wouldn't think about is there's a I'll
put your pen down on the table will blah
blah blah and you would know exactly
what I'm talking about why that's
because they don't have a single object
that represents a mr. chair there's a
table there's one a suitable object
which is what we were doing in the psych
days okay what we call what we think of
as objects in the world or semantic
concepts in the world are really
emergent phenomena in Leila's world
they're actually emergent phenomena that
come out of little cluster of little
schemas about how I would want to talk
about that because it's really true and
this is the old platonic problem right
how do you define a chair precisely the
answer is that's an in complete question
how do i define a chair precisely as I
can for a given purpose so what does
Leela do to do that
I mean of course her vision system is
going to start out by grabbing a chunk
of pixels but it's not going to take
those pixels and it's saying cannot can
these pixels cause states that I can
then use do these pixel relationships
represent states which I can then use as
fodder for making a plan to accomplish
the goal I want to I want to I want to
make so that means you know some of them
are functionally learned behavior about
it's got to be big enough strong enough
to to support me it's got to be an angle
it's going to be wide enough you know
from my bottom and then you know both of
those things are true of the tree stump
as well as a as well as in the as well
as in the chair case you know we don't
have any kind of frame system yet but I
imagine our search is going to be
affected by constrained by that as well
and again that's a kind of a under fit
that humans often often exhibit does not
have stereo vision Lila has very simple
color vision
but remember Lila the agent just talks
to the world through a pipe and has no
initially a assigns no semantics to the
two state primitive state items that
state variables that come over its
connection to the outside world so in
theory you could plug its optic nerve
into its hearing nerve etc and like the
guy did with the ferrets and
we will eventually learn how that world
worked she really has no no concept of
that something that is right now right
now in our in our model the system has
absolute proprioception in the system in
its world so it would get hide off its
ground by moving by and it does not have
does not doesn't in perspective in the
vision system of the moment high off the
ground by basically knowing where it's
had lost it but we're touching it but
going back to what I was saying you know
Lila since Lila composes a set of
primitive items if we were to develop a
stereo camera and have it look at the
world after a while it would start to
build correlations of knowing that I
can't put something I can't let go
something unless I believe my hand it's
in the same height as the thing that I'm
letting go surface but many people sit
on it or consider it yes suitable to sit
on and how would leave a treat that I
mean I believe it's a little over time
learned that certain things with certain
properties a base property a havior
exhibit behavior that is consistent
through standard statistical means we'll
use a neural network to we'd use neural
networks of course to divide and conquer
in these large state spaces but lilo is
not going to grow up with any not going
to be introduced with any inherent
knowledge about that you know about how
balls behave or whatever and I must say
the first time I saw someone sitting on
a ball at a desk I was quite surprised
nobody's great on this spend some time
thinking about it right and that's one
of things were actively working on on
building those models where Leela can
think on her own now so basically Leela
doesn't have to jump off the cliff to no
dropping off a cliff is a bad idea and a
lot of that's like oh but even now when
she looks at something say well what
kind of experiment what I need to do to
decide whether this thing is true or
false right like I saw you sitting on a
ball and you got up I'm probably
personally going try the experiment fall
over or not whatever again Leela's 14
month old child without a lot
moving things but all the all the
mechanisms that are involved in doing
that are in her I don't know if that
sounds like hand wavy answer but that's
that's where we are at the moment okay
so again it's not a monolithic system
with a single you know okay this is our
view of the world everything's built out
of this view of the world this kind of
goes back to what we're saying about how
you know you use different pieces where
they were what we're kind of guiding by
human beings you know human beings
brains have brainstem functions that are
highly compiled and themselves generate
more sophisticated state information
either in the you know like literally in
proprioception in the brainstem or in
recognition in the visual system and so
we're using neural networks to to divide
and conquer like said to divide and
conquer and some of the large parts of
the state space this is a slide for
somebody else but this shows that you
know again you don't necessarily have to
have a lot of you know you don't have a
primitive item of what a piece of wood
looks like but emergently you can build
a synthetic state of oh that's what
that's what a piece of wood looks like
and whenever you see that that function
runs and now I've got that that that
state variable becomes true true and
then it can use plans that are based on
that so how does it build these more
complex plans we use PR J's muddled
precisely of what children do in early
you know an infant in infant development
right so initially Lila wakes up she has
no schemas is what what Piaget called
them of how to relate items to item
state items and to state transitions so
she just begins blindly executing and
it's actually quite boring in the first
few thousand experiments she does which
are mostly just moving one her hand in
one direction or moving her eye in one
direction but after a while she has a
mechanism that that runs over the state
transitions each time an actions taken
to start to look for correlations which
she then
as an inherent heuristic that says try
to reinforce promising sets of
correlations joke don't just hypothesize
them add them to my library but if I
have some that I have prophesized do a
few experiments to decide whether
they're really valid or not and that
process is was called by Piaget
accommodation and the nice thing is that
as you start the code does she does
starts to build more reliable schemas
then she tries to use these reliable
schemas in plans
to increase the value of those schemas
and now starts to learn of how those fit
in how those lead to new subsequent
correlations only focusing on the ones
that she's already found to be valuable
right you're not trying to do an N
squared search of every state
combination in the world at every step
what you're trying to do is to say I've
been successful in this area let me try
to build on the successes that I've
already that I've already had and then
eventually once you've built a set of
that of a believable schemas and
reliable plan she can then branch out
and say well let me explore some parts
of the space where I have not had so
much success before to either drop them
drop these hypotheses or reinforce them
and make them more powerful so to do
that therefore to go back you know one
of the processes we do this is not just
new actions but actually to develop
these new States that I think you mark
you were asking me about the synthetic
states right so she since she's building
this I'll show you some video of this
she builds new state vector new states
that she didn't have before which was oh
I see I see an object that I've learned
otherwise I can't move my hand through
at a particular location whenever I see
that I can't move my hand through that
location and she builds she then then
she can incorporate that kind of state
into her into her model and the
interesting thing is so this is a little
complex picture if you're looking at a
block stirs in the blocks world so on
the left you see there's two blocks in
that yellow in that yellow box is her
vision system so we got one that's
outside her vision one that's in and in
the light green that's actually the
fovea did Regency what
she sees no she doesn't know when she
starts up what's her hand what's the
yellow block
what's anything like that we she has to
learn that all through through
exploration and but she starts to learn
oh if I see something there I cannot
move my hand through it she doesn't know
what it is she doesn't know that that
location is somehow excluded what she
ultimate first she does of course but
ultimately she learns oh when I see if I
learned that I'm excluded there now and
that's correlated was seeing something
there then later when she can move her
hand through and there's nothing there
it doesn't invalidate all her knowledge
about moving it says oh maybe I should
be thinking that if I see something I
can't move it shall I do an experiment
to verify that so as you build this
state here's the experiment we actually
did using open AI a very simple test of
just navigating in a blocks world and we
built the playpen up from you know 30 by
30 up to 200 by 200 which is what they
open open the eye using the open a eye
code and we actually used the winning
opening eye solver for this that was on
their on their leaderboard leaderboard
and not surprisingly because it has to
explore the entire world I mean this is
what you as a human computer programmer
you'd be shocked if you didn't see this
right because you don't want to write a
program that explores the entire board
in every possible position and then
needs to do that in order to learn how
to solve the problem of how do I get
from here to there
Leela because she can do composition
just like a human can that's a much more
linear behavior and how long it takes
her to learn how to solve how to come up
with the solutions to being given ask
that question at any time so I think
I'll skip over this slide I'm gonna come
back to that later because another thing
that's important is I talked about
language okay and one of our team
members is a computational linguist
sorry our team is a very high MIT bias
hope that doesn't offend anyone and
Yuji so the question is how do you
acquire how do you add language to Lila
and again going back to how humans are
guided and how because officially how
humans do it anybody who here is a
parent probably remembers that when your
child is small you were just continually
narrating life to your child right here
we're taking the bowl out no we put it
on the counter you know just like
continually just narrating non-stop of
what's going on so we built a teacher
that narrates at the moment unbelievably
dumb sentences subject-verb-object
sentences to leela which she primary
where she uses almost exactly the same
mechanisms that she does for all other
learning to start to correlate language
with activity now correlating language
activity is a little bit more
complicated than long than correlating
your own volition with that with with
activity because people use language in
a much less structured way and so
sometimes there's ambiguity you'll say
corner because it's in the corner but
you might you know you move leela moves
or head right and we might say it's in
the corner or we might say you moved it
right or we might say you know it's not
you know or it might say before you you
might to point something in the field
there's a there's a red ball over there
and and so Leela has to so we have some
additional mechanism to allow Leela to
have a more broad view of what
linguistic utterances are but apart from
that all of her learning and the
correlative mechanisms that she uses are
exactly the same that she uses to
operate in the physical world and she
uses those resulting graph structures as
she generated to actually generate the
sentences that she makes on this mark at
the moment she has not learned Legation
know at the moment we cannot say that
right now but yes that's right I don't
know what it slows it down well you know
it's I'm glossing over something part of
the reason we don't have that is there's
a representational the question of
whether we should whether it's Leyland
needs negative state objects at all to
operate or not it's also it's a it's a
point of argument with us and we haven't
run very good experiments yet to decide
if Lila you know Lily could be faster
and more just as effective or not with
that but you don't have to go modify the
code to allow that and I'm not sure if
Syrus is waiting to work on that problem
until we resolve some of that I just I'm
not working on the linguistic part of
the other system that's yeah but that's
not an in that case it's not a not this
is the case where I said oh my plan will
not succeed this is no that's no
different from the positive case this is
hence our argument where you know if
I've got something here and I want to
move my hand form it well I've
eventually learned I can't move my hand
through objects that I can see so
therefore I will make a plan that does
not involve that and you know partially
it's a philosophical question huh
right and so do we and and and so is our
concept of negation just an artificial
concept that we've layered on top of our
view of the world and means the whole
world considered nothing of a piano
arithmetic I don't know you know that's
that that's why this is a research
project and at the moment we have
negative items for it I don't I don't
believe that Cyrus has implemented any
negative linguistic functions yet
and then can we say that there's a
negative result or is this am I trying
to play too much into it I think you're
trying to read too much into it because
what happens is a plan can succeed or
fail I mean the plan can be very small
right like I'm I'm gonna remove my my
hands on the table I want to move my
hand down okay I cannot do that and Lila
will eventually learn that it that's not
true if it's not touching something it
can move its hand down but when it's
touching something on the bottom of its
hand it could not move down and just
standard statistics say well that this
operation does not get any more reliable
when it's in this state Oh a different
unrelated operation which is has a
different set of predecessors is
successful well that one will be getting
be more of a cat more likely to be a
candidate for executing a plan so we
would definitely say when we saw that oh
she learned not to do this because that
doesn't work what she really learned was
not to do it because it's not a
candidate path to take now so there's a
philosophical question that I don't know
and right now we planned that we plan to
resolve it like we do with a lot of
arguments well let's just write some
code and find out what seems to work it
could be that I mean there's a whole
bunch I mean just like a deep
philosophical thing oh so more about
some laundry at the moment she only
speaks English I know I'm really
actually since I'm the only non-japanese
speaker on the team I'm really eager for
Leela to also be learning Japanese in
parallel but it's sort of like the i/o
problem we have enough bugs to fix right
now we'll just stick to one my sibling
especially since she really has no she
barely has English grammar at all
at the moment so you're asking me where
Lila is so Lila is
still up in the birth to two years phase
in terms of cognitive development
obviously she can't walk she can't do a
lot of things that little little babies
also do but you know she exhibits
curiosity I mean that's coded into her
right got nothing else to do go learn
some reliability but she has started to
learn you know object persistence so
she's basically in this in this position
of about a 14 month old child it's
actually pretty pretty exciting depends
on how you mentioned we've definitely
been working on a longer than forty
class
what's 14 plus nine right now we've been
working much longer than longer than
that and also a child does it basically
with one brain how many of us have been
working on the code but still that gives
you some kind of idea of where we are I
mean and they both in two cents in one
sense there's a long way to go before
you trust Leela to act like agent from a
science-fiction book but actually that's
pretty good because remember Leela
doesn't have any explicit rules for
things like coordinating vision in touch
okay
for you know moving into by
understanding that you can actually
exert force on on objects she developed
all of those schemas on her own through
experimentation some experimentation
which we gave her you know please move
the blue block into your fovea which by
the way has two solutions typically you
can either grab the blue block and move
it or you can move your eye and she'll
do one or the other depending on on the
situation but again we gave her
sometimes instructions sometimes you
just explore it on her own
but that's how she builds her corpus so
let's look at some of these gold ribbon
things how do I start this
so so here's Lila moving around in a
blocks world think of her as having an
eye with a fovea - region in the middle
that you'll see as I move it there's a
little bounding box that shows you where
where her vision so there's stuff that
she can't see there's stuff that she can
just see coarsely I know there's
something there and then in the fovea -
region she can tell oh it's got a color
and and she can feel proprioceptive lis
that it's got a texture eventually she
learns to correlate correlate those and
then she's looking down on the world now
so that's he or she is just just
exploring now she actually one of my
colleagues found a nanny cam on the web
sorry a mother had posted her nanny cam
video on the web and it was actually
interesting to see that this little kid
sort of like Lila moves around you know
and if you actually look at it she's
like picked something up drops it four
or five times then rolls over and does
something else rolls this thing back and
forth continually do the experiments
using this heuristic that we talked
about oh I'm in this situation let me
repeat the action and see if it if it
gives me the same results and you're
basically building schemas just as
Piaget said basically the same mechanism
that that Leela is using now here's our
schematic view from the physics world of
what Leila's hands doing it's moving
around sometimes it's in the fovea
sometimes it's not it's a pretty good
heuristic to try to keep your hand in
the fovea or whatever you're working on
in the Hova which turns out that's a
heuristic that humans also exhibit if
she doesn't eventually learn to move the
objects if you switch on grappling in
there in the physics world she builds a
whole bunch of schemas around whether
hands is open or closed whether you know
when I touch something if you know if
I'm if I'm touching something and I
close my hand
it's actually more of a magic magnetic
length but still you know and then I
move my hand the thing moves we're
pushing an object from the side at the
moment the only the physics world that
we have that has grasping in it just you
can't move unless you grasp it it's like
she discovered stacking no right now two
dimensional worlds on the computer so
we've got our pretty comfy are you sure
that's deteriorating ready yes you know
actually a show we showed someone not
sure Lou the other day and they were
amazed they're like you've learned how
to do this like no no no this was done
around the time we were born on a pdp-10
yes well I I've got more than that on my
phone these days so push a goal I think
what do we say touch the pointy object
so she made little plans not such moving
pointy hand right left so she moved her
hand down touched it my hands on the
left now the verbal command that has
been programmed the words internet go to
the top right corner and we didn't
really they own what does she know of
top right corner she knows top right
corner only through the emergent
behavior of correlating those words with
times that she found she saw objects or
her hand up in that top right corner
this is yeah this is actually issue lock
hands right moving touch pointy top so
the Linguistics MA the the teacher will
talk while the systems running because
the teacher note can look and know what
the plan is and say you're moving your
hand right or something like that in
this case we gave a command using words
no the person making the video clicked
on that it could have just typed the
words but you know it doesn't have a
whole
auditory system or anything like that
she just runs in the simulation at the
moment probably would not that exciting
for human 14 month old but you know
she's just a computer at the moment
she's I was planning to do that position
one fall I'm moving my hand forward that
it was ivory d-block so she had to make
a new plan in order to achieve to
achieve the goal so she was like to
explain that here have a better
explanation here using some of her
synthesized natural language
she's just moving around randomly he
doesn't know anything at the moment
right she just booted up you know every
time I control see her she dies so in
this case she's dying but now she
started to build schemas this is a
little visualizer it's just a force
directed graph but the interesting thing
about the schemas that she builds is
that you can see they form these
semantic clusters so every time you have
a very simple one you know start out
with an empty one right at the root then
those new very simple ones are forced
directed out and then they seem to they
they tend to form clusters and you can
see the ones that are has she has found
semantically very valuable in achieving
goals they cluster together that would
be this one up here down here there's a
much more barren piece of value either
she hasn't explored it or when she's
explored it hasn't been very valuable so
she hasn't made very more plant many
more more complex schema based on based
on that but as she runs you know she you
can see her attention shifting to
different sorts of things that she as
she moves every time she does it takes
any action it's an opportunity to learn
oh well I mean we have a serialize er so
we can stop her and restart her she
stopped but every time type control see
if you don't save she starts out knowing
nothing about the world she has to start
out building all our schemas over again
there's a certain amount and invest in
it so no two worlds or is that been
saying - to start her up and then have a
run and explore the world and start to
develop an idea of object persistence
like a hundred thousand steps we could
hundred thousand steps Oh on a machine
like this MacBook Pro that's a few hours
no a real human is doing a whole lot of
other stuff right so we're just looking
at a very specific set of things or
correlate with humans but still that's
that's pretty good right I'm a little
confused about the bootstrapping are
there does she start out with schema for
building schema and for what an
experiment no she that is actually part
of her you know construction that's part
of that's actually a piece of code that
we wrote there is a there is an inherent
construction of mechanism that it's a
constructivist model right so there's
constructive mechanism says every time
you take some action can you learn
anything from that action and she's
hired wired to do that what action she
takes is completely dependent on that's
her choice what predecessor state what
goal she was trying to accomplish and
what the state vector looks like is
entirely a result of the physics system
that she's plugged into so if she's
plugged into Mario Brothers then her
view of the physics world what what
action she can take what state what the
state vector of the world looks like is
entirely Mario's world if
she's exploring the blocks world than
her view of what actions she has the
ability to take and what the primitive
state items are that come back every
time she looks at the world are entirely
dependent by the blocks world simulator
or ultimately the robot I want to hook
her up to or whatever right so she the
the algorithms in within Lila the stuff
that that we wrote the lines of code
that we wrote make no presuppositions as
to the semantics of any activity or the
semantics of any state variable she
applies those semantics as she learns
how they relate yes all right I mean
there's other people I mean you know
Gary Drescher was a student of Marvin's
I actually met him when I worked for
Seymour so I think he was working for
Seymour at that time one of mine kuiper
students also worked on on some
work-related on an Piaget and the
constructivist learning I mean
constructivist learning was kind of
popular into 80s like so many things got
nuked by AI winter so you know we're
looking at work you know we've been
looking at other people's work and and
and reading Piaget to decide okay what
kind of mechanisms do we want to emulate
but to the greatest degree possible we
don't want to have any preconception of
what the world looks like now if you
start to look more about the human
obviously the human visual system
generates a whole bunch of synthetic
state variables you know because of its
edge finders and life and recliners and
all of that all that stuff probably we
want to go that direction for the vision
system because that is the thing that's
most relatable to what humans do but as
far as the core reasoning system it
doesn't know anything and has no need to
know about any of those things
actions isn't it to get mastery over the
materials involved rather than because
they think the outcome will be different
for the identical action well
maybe I love that question because I
mean I've just I'm trying to avoid being
witty about it because I love that
question so much I mean first of all why
do babies do X I have no idea of course
why babies do X but if I were to take a
PSA it in stance to the question of what
babies do from a computer scientists
point of view I would say babies repeat
action in order to build schemas that
have statistic that are that have
statistical value for that in order to
be able to accomplish two goals so it's
funny I was just visiting my cousin and
her grandchild was visiting and he's
also about 14 months actually and a
little bit older 18 months and we were
talking and he was sitting at the coffee
table and he took a coaster or
rectangular coaster and he stood put it
on the coffee table which is about right
height for him and he walked around I
loved watching this because he got to
the corner he rotated 90 degrees and he
walked around he did that about 4 times
and his mother said oh he loves to clean
he loves to copy what we do and he sees
us cleaning and I watched him and he
maintained the alignment of the edge of
this coaster with the edge of the table
all the way around and after you're done
in about 4 or 5 times he stopped right
in front of me rotated the coaster which
is square 90 degrees and then did the
whole action over again right and I'm
like this kid is discovering a billion
transformation that's right that's right
and you know he is hard at work and what
he's done is he's like first of all he's
like ok I verified that this thing is
invariant plus you know he's helping
learning to walk he's doing a whole 50
different experiments or 5,000 different
experiments at the same time but then he
does this other really great experiment
I'm gonna change one variable is the
rest of the behavior invariant wow
that's going to give me a ton of
reinforcement for all
open ah Polly of really interesting
schemas and then like little kid you saw
rolling around if you just did this once
like you're walking down the street and
you rest your hand on a railing and
mommy says take your hand off that dirty
thing right well you might not ever
encounter another railing in your life
now that may not be so bad because okay
how much do you want to learn about a
railing if you never saw one again but
why not repeat your experiment because
you're already in the state where you
can repeat it because then you might use
that plan for something else and be able
to build a more general and more
powerful schema which are actually more
specific if you think about how it works
the outcome of an identical action is
different than it was before well if I
have a ball on the edge of the table and
I push my hand over and the ball rolls
in some random direction first of all
the next time I push my hand no ball
moves so like a dog goes gets the ball
puts it up next time I push it it goes
in a different direction but at least
I've learned that it falls off and then
maybe you know I because I'm a kid and
I've got enormous amount of patience to
do this kind of thing eventually to
discover that how my hand is oriented
relative to the ball I mean that to me
is why babies do it now you know this is
a guy who read Piaget who knows C++ and
Lisp right so I could be completely
confabulating that but that seems to be
to be the basic answer to your question
that's right electrical system had is
deterministic the human nervous system
is in deterministic there's a lot of
noise and register kostik control some
people the repetition as a function in
the in the in the mechanics of the how
the nervous system works in a human
being which is different
yeah no system but that deny that that
doesn't negate the value of what you're
doing it's just there is a difference
and exactly I mean you know I got this
hundred Hertz machine with 80 Giga
neurons in it right and a 1050 fan-out
that's a lot more nodes and I could ever
fit in a computer that I can buy
probably in my lifetime on the other
hand the computers I got I buy my
lifetime I've a you know three gigahertz
clock speed you know you're right we're
using different algorithms I'm pretty
sure that the correlational mechanism
that we use to do construction is not
may not even be that close to what the
hell's going on in this you know piece
of hamburger up there but it exhibits
behavior which is similar and the
important that's why I said it we're
we're guided by what you must do but we
don't try to emulate what humans do and
the important part of that is you know
you can't tell the difference if you
can't tell the difference it works right
is that I can I can if I toss somebody
to Eugene
he'll probably catch it right and you
also like touch something Leela I want
her to order catch it I don't really
care if Eugene's process to catch it and
Leela says to catch it or if I trip and
we you know you genes can pull his leg
out of the way I want the robot to do
the same thing where catch me or
whatever I bet I I want that I want
machines that exhibit what we would call
common sense which is they just do what
we expect right such a vague word that
was another one of likes stumbling
points right common sense just means the
stuff that I expect to know that no one
really told me because I learned it
iteratively and I've observed everyone
else learned it I'm sorry I learned it
experimentally and I vote I learned a
bunch of other people also learn urdu
experimentally so if Leela experiments
was something physiologically similar to
what humans have then probably she will
exhibit behavior that I find
comprehensible that's kind of the whole
thesis in a nutshell on that topic
yes a system for backtracking and
debugging why why did you think this or
how did you come up with well we can ask
her why did you think that plan right
when she when she moved her hand I think
I might have another video where she
tries to move her hand know where she
tries to make a do I finish running this
video I didn't here's one I think in
this video she actually fails to achieve
football all right and and then does so
I know that's just a pretty picture now
she's been running about twenty five
twenty five thousand steps
Oh ten thousand steps okay so here's
yeah this is kind of interesting this
actually is exactly your quick thank you
for asking this question at this point
of the video Eugene so here's that's a
pretty uninteresting goal right I
started my hand on the side move to the
other side there's nothing in the way
all right I did it
Rahmi she's learned that that plan can
be reliable when she doesn't see
anything in that path or she hasn't
learned that it is unreliable if there
is something in the past so now we move
her back a bit and we move this thing
out of the way and then we go back to
the go back up to starting point and now
tell her we've told her to move back to
that same goal state can't do it she
goes around it okay
think oh that video that video cuts off
she doesn't give it so we could ask her
what happened you might have heard to
say his block she'd say I tried I don't
know in that particular plan whether she
tried to hit it was blocked made a brand
new plan that involved not going through
something that's blocked or whether
she'd seen it over time she'll learn oh
if I see something I can't go through
there and you can just ask her how does
your plan work and at the moment like I
said she actually tells you the plan so
I'm actually supposed to run out of time
so just to get something else here is
Mario she's playing Mario and what's
interesting this this is again open AI
Mario state vectors but you know she
doesn't ever play ten thousand games
nope she just died I think I think this
is about 25 games and she did something
interesting here which is that she
learned you know she's kind of okay I
can hop around I'm exploring what I've
learned I can you know sometimes
something interesting happens when I
when I jump up and and here she goes or
am I supposed to say he because there's
Mario Brothers I don't know anyway this
is interesting so after 25 games Mario
has learned oh I can still use the
heuristics that I used I knew to play in
a level even though this level looks
very different from the level I saw
before okay the geometric guys you were
just released I can set a paper on this
problem what they did of course a lot
better than this on the same hand they
built it a they built a Mario playing
game this is exactly the same program
that was moving in the blocks world in
this case she hadn't she hadn't loaded
her blocks world knowledge but we could
try that and she did eventually learned
Oh my state pictures behave differently
we just haven't figured out yet how to
really make that really exciting like
people don't do so great when they lose
their hands either I'm just going to
show you one other random picture which
i think is really cool so this is a
different graph of her state space in
this case it relates not the schemas but
the state items and there's a lot of
this actually just probably well I'll
just tell you this so there's a lot of
dense information in the middle of of
here where she's learned a lot of
schemas about how items relate like
objects in whatever again there's a
force directed graph right what's really
interesting is that sort of hoarded
structure on the top if this were I just
flipped this out of a demo but if you
were to move the mouse over those nodes
you'd find all of those nodes are
actually reflect prosciutto prospective
locations of the hand and the eye
right so just like our visual system has
a 2d map in it she developed a 2d map
which you know was forced apart by the
force graphics I think it's actually a
coincidence but we were just so excited
when we saw that because it was it
seemed like a fitting it seemed yes a
mental map it just seemed like a
physiological analog probably actually
isn't but it's so cool right it's like
oh there's a back of my head with medium
visual system alright anyway I'm pretty
much out of time so I'm going to end my
talk there unless are a few more
questions I think I've a couple minutes
[Applause]
existing yeah so we have a research
implementation written in Java and then
we have another implementation written
in C++ that's aimed to be higher you
know significantly higher performance
scalable multi-threaded etc of course
it's much less mature than the Java
implementation so it's it fails much
faster but those those tools then all
those visualization systems just written
in JavaScript in node so all that force
directed graph stuff you know one of my
one of my partners he's just like Oh
like as fast as we like oh be really
interesting to see a picture of that
he's just pulls out a few node modules
and there we got a visualizer it's kind
of astonishing to me then a bunch of the
physics simulators that we use are
written in various languages Python
whatever all the stuff that ties out
into tensorflow
is Python code that the system calls and
I think that's all the languages that
we're that we're using no just just
graph structure I I have a serialize ER
that will see utilize to to a sequel
database but that's it
why wouldn't you just let this learn
continuously until it makes a mistake
and then back up to the point and then
where the mistake was made and fix the
code and then continue learning what
answers to that question one of us or is
it's a research project and so you know
you need to recompile the code and not
again it's a need to control C maybe
save your state pick it up from there
yeah uh when you talk about a mistake
what's a mistake
I mean if Lila tries to do something and
is unable to do it that's not a mistake
she's just unable to do it you know I
try to walk through the wall I can't go
through the wall I learned something
instead of saying that was a mistake
mistake is if you mean a buck a bug in
the code yeah but in there's another
thing which is you know this Java
program completely drowns the part of
the impetus to go to some different
technology is that just this big single
threaded thing with the Java memory
model you know fills up your computer
and you know a few hours and then it
slows to a crawl so but ultimately yeah
when there's I really think of there as
being one Lila implementation and she
just learns we thought about what fleet
learning means for a system like this as
opposed to you know traditional neural
network right how how can two Lila
instances running in a small machine
that's wrong how can they reconcile I
mean that's what humans do right we talk
basically I'm just trying to cause
experiments to happen in your head when
I talk to you this whole conversation or
talk I'm giving here as a way to try to
cause little experiments to happen in
your head that create schemas that are
somehow I believe parallel to water in
my head so maybe that's the path but
yeah ultimately you'd want Lila to just
continue aggregating knowledge because
the smarter she gets the more
interesting things she can do and still
it doesn't give up the ability to do the
simple things so maybe I should say the
reason we could control scene today is
due to the limitations of technology and
our implementation and in theory Lila
could even talk to different kinds of
physics systems you know already if you
were to cut off if you had Lila with two
arms you cut one off she
what I'm learned that okay I can no
longer things that involve moving my
left hand just stop being reliable you
know or she we could give her a brand
new sense she'd eventually learned to
just integrate that new sense and you
know what she knew the first
computerized trading system it was a
structural change in the stock market
and this was at a time when a million
dollars are still worth a lot of money
and it was losing a million dollars a
minute and there was no way to turn it
off and so one of the traders took an
axe and went around and started putting
cables until he could disable its video
video of that in the show I'm Japanese
so let's think about that story in a
different way though okay if you have a
child and your child is learning to
drive and it's crashed a few cars you
don't control see your child you just
it's really frowned upon what you do
instead is you buffer the child from
automobiles right so if you think of
Lela being an agent you do just like you
would with any other human being or like
don't touch that dial
rather than control seeing the human but
that's true with humans as well like I
was just starting the beginning with
Eugene right humans overfit all the time
I mean anti-vaxxers well we also
unfortunately have ways of control
seeing humans but but yeah and in a more
just world we don't actually control see
them but we do buffer them from the
things that cause trouble anyway
all right well Ivan enormous leader to
do list of things to work on some of
which were brought up here we have
someone who said they might give us some
money to actually pay us to actually
work on this so if anybody else wants to
participate in that that would be great
that would be just another to-do item
but you know there's a whole bunch of
linguistic questions there's a bunch of
experiments on let me there's just
plumbing right how I get the system to
scale there's a whole bunch of
algorithmics things I mean some of these
some of these algorithms don't scale and
we're gonna have to develop frame system
of some sort we've been talking about
that the system doesn't have very good
temporal prediction right now right I
mean it doesn't really know throw a wall
and it's going to do all this curve and
all that stuff I have a theory of how to
do that and so that's going to one
things I I'll be working on there's you
know I oh I actually want to move for a
little robot around have it navigate and
see how the system you know can deal
with that right now
time works in lockstep but of all of its
physics worlds likely like most of the
open AI thing this time is to scream
right but actually the real world time
is not discrete so you know we got a lot
a whole bunch of work to do to figure
out how to handle that kind of stuff so
there's like everything from ordinary
programming to think about how to bring
up some more complex capability and the
grammar is very simple and fortunately
none of my to-do items are on the
computational linguistic side right a
little about that but all of it is you
know how do we bring wila
up to the point where she could actually
work or alongside a human to make their
life easier in a predictable way right
preferably not flying drones to control
see people in other countries so I don't
know if that answers your question
Oh half a dozen people four years or 35
years depending on how you look at it
right you know I know how many hours has
been talking to Marvin about stuff like
this right you paid to work on this
stuff so you can look at that either way
how many lines of code high round the
whole system is like 30,000 lines of
code so we probably wrote 300 or 400
thousand lines of code to get there
that's a great price when you consider
how many million lines of code with
those 10 is okay we just can't do this
[Laughter]
[Applause]
that's my hope
there's lots of things that people do
that really their life would be much
better a few months we're doing it I
mean if machines were doing it can we go
back to the bridge and the boat the
piece of the bridge yeah how much your
name would be required I understand that
situation I'm not driving over the
bridge for example not as much as you
might think I mean my belief is that
that's that's probably not as hard as
you think I mean because humans use a
lot of interesting heuristics in those
kinds of situations like remember the
Tesla car that decapitated this guy and
and of course the explanation for
Tesla's well it was white and it was a
sky so you know we're like Vanna von
Braun we just couldn't care less and
yeah and that was probably true you
couldn't see it but a human would have
done a couple of things a human would
have seen the back of the truck and the
tractor and would have had some idea
that typically there's something in
between right and the second thing the
human does is they slow down right you
drive when you can run off some very
high level schemas that you already have
got right
I learned to drive in Boston so you know
basically you touch the car in front of
you kind of things right but as soon as
you lose your comfort zone where those
high level schemas are applicable you
immediately slow down because you get to
start making more complicated plans from
scratch or at least from more you've got
to come out we go synthesize the plans
because again them being composable
means oh I'm in a state where I can use
this I'll just use it right away oh no I
got to make a new one or depend on
something it's less reliable maybe I
better be looking at each step along the
way people do that kind of thing all the
time right and you know but you don't
want to write all those cases down by
hand no the boat has this piece of metal
attached to it it's not that the piece
of metal looks a little bit like the
thing ahead of you you know you
typically don't see boats with weird-ass
pieces of metal in the front of them
except in very unusual cases and in fact
if you were going around in if you
routinely drove over bridges in an
industrial city where do they had some
of those boats that pushed other barges
around and had big Rou bars on the front
of them then in fact you might in fact
fall into this problem you would over
fit and that a human would also over fit
in such a case going back to my you know
meat loaf and an cat case right you
sometimes will have trouble if you
stumbled across a meat loaf all
wandering around in your backyard
because you just don't expect to find
one unless you have a small child and
and those are the kinds of it means to
me it's okay it's okay if the machine
makes similar mistakes to humans I
really of course it shouldn't right you
should never make a machine that's why I
want the machine right let the humans
make the mistakes but realistically you
know people are full of flaws and we
build structures or a-hunting linked
with those flaws and let's make machines
have been into those kinds of structures
and okay you know you find that out all
right people get into situations you
like I would never do that but they were
in an environment that was familiar to
them and so they didn't recognize that
barrel they were in it she brought up
the Hal analogy for instance I didn't
know
vizor keep Abravanel Minnelli's but
remember what's the name david sum total
where's the rico center i'm more curious
about how other portrayals of machines
in the media which are semantic in the
nature actually affect how people think
about robots because i work for an
agency for 30 years which had a lot of
skepticism for robots and they don't
want to get AI rotate around Mars oh
that that agency sent all tons of robots
out where people couldn't go repair them
we have lots of internal discussions and
actually I actually recall there were
two robots in interstellar tars and I
can't remember the name of the other one
there lot of people who thought that
those were actually pretty good for
trails of robots and one of them self
sacrifice himself for the mission
visible to at the end of the movie
embassy blue interstellar well so a lot
of people are afraid of robots but I was
saying that I was just looking out for
my parents the past couple of weeks and
interesting thing is that my mother
would be happier with a robot to look
after her than a human and the reason is
that she would feel weak if a human had
to do this thing
it's embarrassed yeah it's embarrassing
it's like people who clean the house
before the cleaning yeah and she would
not feel that she does not feel when she
uses her phone as a prosthesis that that
implies anything any moral failing in
her right and so a robot that fried an
egg for her or helped her up the steps
or ran a bath or any of those things
would not in her case feel any kind of
de munition in her sense of humanity
which is counter to what a lot of the
science fiction stories and the Golem
stories think about robots okay right
Thanks
you